because we've been hearing from the
european commission who have said a firm
no uh to what lord frost said earlier on
in the house of commons today
yeah the uh the timeline of this is that
lord frost
stood up made his statement it became
clear that
the british government wanted a complete
renegotiation
of the northern ireland protocol the
initial response was muted frankly from
my perspective it was a series of
of messages coming to me from people who
said
rolling eyes emojis uh the text being
we've heard this all before we are fed
up of this rhetoric but then we got a
statement from the
vice president of the european
commission maril sefkovic who is
effectively now in charge
of enacting brexit negotiations and
marissevich said this
we will continue to engage with the uk
on the suggestions made today we are
ready to continue
to seek creative solutions within the
framework of the protocol
in the interest of all communities in
northern ireland however he said
we will not agree to a renegotiation
of the protocol and since then
a number of uh diplomats here have said
to me read what uh sefkovic said
and that is our line too i think most of
the eu
has pretty quickly rolled in behind now
one of the things that annoys the
european union enormously
is the suggestion that they hear from
the british government that it is
they the european nations who are
jeopardizing
the good friday agreement uh the eu
response is inevitably
that one of their member states ireland
is
clearly clearly fundamental
to the good friday agreement and that
they are acting on their behalf and to
that end prime minister of ireland um
hell martin
uh was speaking a little bit earlier and
giving his reaction determination i
think to see some sort of movement
but also he knows that he's part of the
eu here's what he had to say
the european union has always been ready
to engage in a positive way
there has to be quit pro-quo there has
to be engagement on both sides
european union stands ready to engage
with the united kingdom in relation to
these issues
and that's where it rests right now
let me give you a bit of reaction also
that's come to me from senior diplomats
here in brussels those who would be
involved
in the renegotiations one just came to
me and said
brussels has grown wary of the tory
party constantly being perpetrated and
victim of its own actions
the northern ireland protocol was a
stepping stone for the trade agreement
you can't alter one and expect the other
to stay
that by the way raising the that were
you
somehow to persuade the eu to to strip
out the european court of justice and
renegotiate the northern ireland
protocol there is a belief here that
that would mean having to reopen talks
around the entire withdrawal agreement
for everyone uh who celebrated the end
of brexit talks
that is the specter that now sits on the
horizon and this from another very
senior figure
in european politics northern ireland
protocol was negotiated and signed by
boris johnson
it was ratified by the uk parliament we
now expect the uk to
implement what it has negotiated signed
and ratified
no ifs no buts no excuses that is a
theme you hear
a lot here that you the uk signed up to
this you have to put it in action you
can't
buy a house get to the point where you
hand over the money and then say it's
outrageous how much you're charging me
their contention is always that britain
signed up for this
and by the way one final thought the
idea
uh according to eu diplomats i've spoken
to that a they would reopen negotiations
but b
that they would take the european court
of justice out of this deal
they say is utterly fanciful there is a
thought in their minds that this is all
a stalling
tactic that if the uk government really
is proposing this
then everyone knows that this is a
proposal that is simply
unacceptable